Speaker 1: All right, let's hear from some
of you right now. You can call in via the
David Pakman show Discord at David Pakman
dot com slash discord. Let's start today
with Spiel from Nashville, Tennessee.
Am I pronouncing that correctly?
Speaker 3: Hey. Yeah, that's correct. Beautiful.
Speaker 1: What's on your mind today?
Speaker 3: I guess I just wanted to say, you know,
does like wood, Democrats may be losing in 2020
to they like Republicans, maybe gaining
seats in 2022 actually help Democrats in 24,
given the kind of swing cycle of these elections.
Speaker 1: I don't think so for two different
reasons. Number one, the whole swing
nature of of of these elections is midterms
after the party in the White House changes in
the immediately previous election. So it's it's
not just it's all swings, so it's better in 24 for
Democrats if they lose in 22. I don't know of any
historical data that would suggest that it's also
sort of acceleration east in a way the idea that
by making things get worse, you then create
circumstances in which things get better.
And historically, it's just not work that
way. Like we've looked at whether that's
a thing and it really isn't. It's really been
like the big progressive gains have been made
through incremental progress and continuation.
The progressive era late 19th century up until
about 1915 civil rights era, the new deal era. I
kind of mentioned them out of order there. So no,
I don't. I mean, it's totally reasonable question
to ask. The only caveat to that spiel would be
if it's not about making things worse by having
Republicans win in 22 or whatever. But if the
perceived danger levels for twenty four are higher
for left wing voters because Republicans win in
twenty two and then it motivates them in some way.
Maybe there would be an argument to be made there,
but overall I just think Democrats would
be best served to do as well as possible
in twenty two. And then again in 2004, I wouldn't
play these kind of back and forth games with it.
Speaker 3: OK. Yeah, that makes
sense, because I feel like. Yeah,
definitely. You know, whatever people or whatever
can get Democrats to go out and vote more in talk
to me seems like most advantageous for Democrats,
right? So thanks for taking my call, man.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you spiel
from Nashville. Thank you so much.